so
i've never done that on sebas before
i've never done that
with the ken on you before
so
a lot of teachers they only use their
devoted uk because they know that
they're already tuned in but what i do
is i'll perhaps sort of look around and
i'll just you know i'm just showing you
now i'll look around and i'll go
because i'll call the person up
because i've plugged into them they
don't have to really be plugged into me
some people you can't do it on
okay some people
you know you've got two yins or you've
got
two yangs you know it's so you can't do
when is this going to help you
so the next uh come up please so the
next uh thing is
did you feel that on the hand
okay so stand there and when i raised my
hand like this
that's my my finger is just doing that
on his body
and as
you said quite rightly
i don't know if i felt that or not
so with danny
i'm gonna go like that and i know where
i'm feeling here and i'm feeling it
about there but now i've told you and
him he'll more than likely think that he
feels it there but
do you feel me going through it no okay
but i know that i've got that point
so when he say lifts for this for
showman
i've got the same feeling see so when he
lifts my hand i've got to have my timing
correct because
i plugged in to him
his energy
he doesn't know i've plugged into his
energy but when he lifts it
so that's why i'm his puppet in the end
because
my timing has to be right
if you don't look for this type of
connection what happens is he lifts and
you go oh right so this is mechanical
you know you're ready it goes
i've got it i got it i've got it
but a certain level he'll lift it
you can't be out of timing because you
become him
all right
go back or hop or somewhere okay
so
so then it gets lighter you can ask me
questions in a minute
all right that was a little bit of
physical as well
so you use
a mixture of physical
and energy
what i do is i
where can it help you in daily life
you're already doing it without knowing
it
you might say
oh i've been a bit lazy i should go for
a walk
and you're thinking
i just don't want to go for walk that's
the outside mind sort of saying that
you're not gonna be
but
when you go to meet somebody like
perhaps i'll come you know meet you for
the first time and i come up i already
know about here whether i'm gonna like
you or not so you must all know what i'm
talking about there
before you even shake their hand or
there's something that tells you
and you go and if you think about it you
think how can i be that
rude really because they might be a nice
person
but they might be another yin or you
know they're just
so you're working on this already
without knowing it
does anybody have any questions at this
stage
no okay
let's have a look again so what you're
going to do is you're going to with your
partner charmander
coat the guys
be really careful because we haven't
done any warm-ups i just want you to
work out
how much timing
you've got like this
you can do it left and right i'm doing
it for you
so you see
all right and as you get better you've
got to work hard with your mind now
all right so i'm going the same way i'm
now pulling him
mentally so let's do it slowly i'm
coming here and i'm coming here
all right
if you can do that then do it if not use
half technical
physical
half mental
so i'm doing the same techniques as you
but i'm working at it i'm working on it
from a different
level or else it would be after let's
face it after 50 years of doing the same
techniques it'd be pretty boring
you know
so i have to be
i have to be working when i'm doing all
this stuff on something
different
so this coming together here
now if i put coke you in in other words
a ball of my energy
i don't really need to hit him with a
lot but i hit him with
the feeling of that
feeling of that but it's in my intention
i'm not blank so i'll go whereas he's
not going to go anywhere but ball
okay
there's very limited even though out of
all of you there's very limited pete
numbers who would be interested in doing
this
it might be interesting to listen to
but you won't want to be doing it a lot
because it's
too hard to
understand really
way you do it is
instead of having a conversation all
night about
oh i've done this and all can i do that
again
you're going in and out of uh zanshin's
ancient just means awareness
if you actually trained the whole lesson
without any uh talking
you would actually have that connection
between you and your partner
and when you walk to another partner you
know you bow the next time to another
partner you'll go
i ain't got the same connection with
this one
so you start working in different ways
with this energy you start going ah you
know i come out and i go ah this is a
good energy to work with
uh this one's a bit weaker
oh that one's strong i can really
you know so you you you get this
information and when you're in a fight
situation a real situation
you realize that what you have to do is
you have to be big
expand your energy
but with your voice
you talk very calmly and you say to them
i don't want to fight you look at your
age look at me i've got no chance but
you don't say i've got no chance of
winning if you go small then they're
going to get bigger
but what you do is you actually span you
go look i've got no chance
i don't want to go
in the hospital all night can we talk
about this
and then you're working actually you're
best i could however because you're
you're being strong expansive but it's
about energy and then if they were to
attack you then you should i say should
be okay all right so if you can just uh
do the shomonucci
on each other
if you're doing it too fast you're
you're not going to about to get it
so you've got to
you've got to do it at your pace tell
them slow down if you're
if you're not feeling it
then i can determine whether i receive
it
or enter it
see perfect blend there
because he didn't know whether he was
going to attack me or whether i was
attacking him so i got him right in the
middle place
so you're going to do very slowly
you're trying to get that you're trying
to get
his energy lifting your hand up
it comes down
and then you do a coat of ice that you
all know please do it softly because you
haven't warmed up
if you think that
he's you've got this timing together but
you can enter
then ask yourself i done that
physically or i done that i decide to go
in
when it becomes
that
what i didn't choose
from now i'm going to go in
from that
so i chose to go in
that's not kind of energy connected
that's that's me determined
and you've got this energy
so this is all dominating domineering
right i don't know i don't want to lose
you
uh what i'm talking about
um but try it and see what feedback you
get about yourself